de camino a convertirse en un estado
fallido la advertencia más dura hasta
ahora de naciones unidas mientras
mianmar sigue deslizándose hacia el caos
en su último informe sobre la brutal
represión naciones unidas- detalla los
relatos de testigos de los movimientos
masivos de tropas en el noroeste un
movimiento que según los analistas tiene
como objetivo terminar con la
resistencia local
su objetivo son los chinos que son
combatientes feroces de la diferencia de
las otras organizaciones étnicas armadas
están mal equipados así que van a tratar
de atacar al eslabón más débil
wikileaks el relator especial de la onu
sobre mianmar tomei rius declaró el
viernes ante la asamblea general que la
inacción del mundo probablemente
provocará más atrocidades masivas
añadiendo que los habitantes del país
asiático crean que el mundo la onu ya no
se preocupan una cosa es segura cada vez
son más las naciones que cambian de
estrategia prefiriendo comprometerse con
la junta militar gobernante en lugar de
cerrarles el paso por completo un cambio
de táctica parcialmente admitida por
eeuu en una de cumbre de la asociación
de naciones del sudeste asiático asean
por eso estamos aquí para pensar cuál es
el camino a seguir que podría funcionar
realmente para intentar cambiar la
perspectiva de la junta pero también ya
sabes cómo podemos hacerlo de una manera
que no empeoren nuestros problemas
la propia junta militar golpista sigue
excluida de la cumbre los países vecinos
acusan al ejército de llevar a cabo
violaciones masivas de los derechos
humanos desde que tomó el poder por un
golpe de estado en febrero más de 1000
civiles fueron asesinados desde entonces
y miles más han sido encarcelados
naciones unidas señaló que la tortura es
generalizada y ni siquiera los niños se
han librado